bonsoir bienvenue en basse normandie
nous sommes toujours en direct du
village des jeux équestres mondiaux à
quand le village est fermée aujourd'hui
on se dit que c'est un peu dommage que
les enfants auraient pu en profiter en
ce dernier jour de vacances
mais quand le comité d'organisation a
arrêté le calendrier il y a deux ans et
bien la date de la rentrée a été fixé au
1er septembre
entre temps ça a changé le village est
fermé on reparlera des jeux équestres
un peu plus tard mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est la rentrée avant celle
des élèves demain celle des professeurs
du public aujourd'hui
reportage au collège guillaume de
normandie à caen
si tu prends zones prioritaires
d'aurélie nizri et de loïc ph
or 30 collège guillaume de normandie à
caen le personnel administratif a fait
sa rentrée il ya déjà une semaine c'est
désormais au tour t53 enseignants de
reprendre le chemin de l'école une
rentrée préparer soigneusement par
madame la principale c'est une journée
extrêmement important parce que c'est
une journée où on donne en quelque sorte
la feuille de route aux enseignements ou
en fait vers un groupe et où quelque
part on donne le la l'année scolaire à
venir
c'est aujourd'hui sa quatorzième rentrée
en tant que chef d'établissement
mais chaque année différentes madame la
principale a donc pris le temps
d'étudier ou les nouveaux textes dont
d'informer son équipe et c'est reparti
donc on va parce que là je vois faire
tourner il faut gilles iron man qui vont
m'attendre et je l histoire les
spectateurs c'est lui qui est venu à
tous sans accueil des petits nouveaux
mise en place d'ateliers pédagogiques
appelle des priorités du collège
cette pré rentrée c'est l'occasion pour
les profs se remettre dans le bain les
plus où tu es avait pris un peu d'avancé
car tu allais est prêt depuis plusieurs
jours je fais référence heures de
français j'ai pas autant de choses que
les professeurs de mathématiques mais
oui j'ai préparé mes dossiers par classe
j'ai tout
10h lors de la pause où tombent
récréatif et de convivialité pour les
enseignants tout juste rentré de
vacances demain les cloches sonneront à
8h30 pour accueillir les petits sixièmes
et leurs parents une journée
d'adaptation rien qu'en poule
et aujourd'hui quand c'était la rentrée
dépassait ce la première année commune
aux études de santé le casus par lequel
passent entre autres les futurs médecins
ces étudiants ont pu découvrir leur tout
nouvel établissement qui a été inauguré
ce matin mais cet après midi ils sont
rentrés chez eux impossible de faire
cours en raison d'un problème sur les
petits boxeurs 250 étudiants inscrits on
est obligé de connecter des fils de
profs et dans un amphi et son corps est
vrai que percuter en fille d'à côté de
moi et là pour des tests qu'on a fait ce
matin ça fonctionnait visiblement c'est
la connexion entre et des amphis ce film
par ondes radio et 1000 personnes chacun
avec son portable référence et le
système marche pas toujours et cette
première dans l'académie de caen pour
s'adapter aux difficultés budgétaires
que connaissent certaines familles la
lunch box fait son entrée au collège
notre-dame à alençon désormais les
élèves pourront apporter leur repas le
midi d'amiens mignot guillaume book la
lunch box c'est ça une petite boîte
métallique dans laquelle les enfants
amènent un repas à réchauffer au
bain-marie pour après servir aux élèves
attendaient les jeunes et il ya
désormais deux fils cantine classique
lunch box sur une centaine de 2000
pensionnaires ils sont déjà une
quarantaine à avoir adopté ce nouveau
système nouveau bouton moins cher et
malté meilleur face et bio un repas
comme à la maison
et bien évidemment de substantielles
économies préparant une fois le dit
acheter le coût de la cantine est divisé
par 5 ont payé leur repas dans kaki plan
de 1,5 en mai il faut savoir qu'ils
auront fourni le danger donc là ça prend
pour les familles aussi
on se voit bien quand on fait ses
courses les dressé par michel voilà
alors qu'un élève qui mangent à la
cantine classique on va dire reprises à
5 euros 80 lorsqu'il est inscrit à denis
constant pour la nuit la lunch box est
déjà victime de son succès la direction
est pour l'instant en rupture de stock
merci méthionine c'est bien vu dans
l'actualité également il y a quinze ans
éclate et lafargue d'aspiration de ceux
mettant un médecin habilité à ti sur
seul dans le calvados de disparition de
sa seconde épouse et de leurs deux
enfants est l'une des plus mystérieuses
de ces dernières années un an lui a été
rendu il a deux enfants le bodhran
depuis quinze ans jour pour jour le
mystère reste entier sur ce que l'on
appelle faire godard un dossier
officiellement clos depuis deux ans pour
la justice qui a prononcé un non-lieu
après 13 ans dans kate avec moyens
considérables
plus de 80 commission rogatoire dont 18
à l'étranger ont été effectués des
dizaines d'enquêteurs et de magistrats
ont été mobilisés pour un résultat
minimes le 1er septembre 1999 le médecin
caennais yves godard embarque avec ses
deux enfants camille et marcus à bord
d'un voilier à saint malo pour une
croisière au large des côtes bretonnes
quelques jours plus tard la nex de son
bateau et retrouver les recherches sont
officiellement lancés les aucune trace
de la famille ou du voilier en mer à
terre les enquêteurs trouvent du sens
dans la quête du mythe singaré sur le
port ce qui les conduit à son domicile à
tilly-sur-seulles dans le calvados où là
encore du sang a coulé c'est celui de
marie france sa seconde épouse
un mandat d'arrêt est alors lancée à
l'encontre du docteur godard toujours
introuvable lamure 30 ans quelques
indices un sac avec ses papiers jusqu'à
la découverte d'un crâne
il s'agit de celui du camille un beau
lancer enquêteurs sur l'île de man sur
l'île de lewis en écosse on l'aurait vu
aux quatre coins du monde et finalement
nulle part en 2001 des cartes
professionnelles et bancaire du docteur
godard sont retrouvés intacts sur une
plage en 2006 un tiberi un peu murs sont
repêchés en mer laden parle il s'agit
bien dit godard
jamais les corps de marie-france et
marcus godard dont été retrouvé alors
est-ce un drame familial un assassinat
il paraît improbable d'obtenir âge pour
la vérité sur cette affaire qui a
défrayé la chronique et alimenté tant de
fantasmes
passons maintenant aux jeux équestres
mondiaux qui entrent donc dans l'ordre
deuxième semaine aujourd'hui n'y a pas
de compétition le village est fermé et
cette question que font les spectateurs
étrangers de tes jeux des jeux équestres
eh bien c'est fini le maire et patrick
merde on nous croiser quelques-uns de
ses d'arromanches arromanches-les-bains
attire moins dans la température de
l'eau que par celle du style de port
artificiel
pourtant la foule ne se coupe pas dans
les rues du bourg
l'office de tourisme a même enregistré
depuis dimanche une baisse de
fréquentation de 5 compte pourtant parmi
ces touristes qui se font plus rares
difficile de repérer ceux venus assister
aux jeux équestres mondiaux pour les
adeptes du cheval son discret mais bien
présent et que notre mère ne pas venir
ici il faut se déplacer si on l'a déjà
vu à la télévision
c'est juste incroyable être autres sites
incontournables le morial jeunes qui se
destinent à l'élevage des chevaux sont
venus des alentours de saint-etienne ils
ont une semaine a dédié aux jeux
équestres
on a fait montre michel tsahal et
visites de base de normandie ensuite on
a fait le horse ball et ensuite on a
fait le reste et c'est important de
venir en plus d'assister aux épreuves de
venir visiter des lieux touristiques
je pense que oui en plus on est vraiment
dans une ville hyper connue avec des
vraiment des moments historiques
particuliers et surtout celui et la
voilà des billetteries ça se confirme
tout va bien notre belle saison se
termine autour du vin ou et là elle se
prolonge avec des journées où on reçoit
2500 3 et inhabituelle
oui ce qui est inhabituel normalement on
avait une espèce de deux temps morts
entre le quai vraiment appuyé du 25 au
10 25 août 10 septembre
et là on le ressent pas à deux temps
morts donc mais pour chiffrer l'impact
des jeux sur les sites touristiques
il faudra patienter jusqu'en septembre
allez revenons maintenant sur la
victoire de l'allemande sandra of art
qui a remporté hier soir le concours
complet de l'épreuve du saut d'obstacles
à d'ornano
une victoire qui est celle d'une france
et de l'élevage bas normands puisque son
cheval up gun nouveau a vu le jour au
molay-littry à famille berlioz qui l'a
fait naître ne touche plus terre sabine
daniel jeu mahler au lion d'angers
en plus avec le temps mais ses premières
compétitions avec sa cavalière oben
nouveau à monter la hauteur de son
talent de ses origines né en normandie
chez yves elisabeth berlioz au haras des
nouveaux le crack est le fruit d'une
jument âgée qui partait à l'abattoir en
ouvrant la porte du camion à des aveux
c'était un oeil un bon oeil quoi bon
comme on aime comme on aime les voir et
puis le physique était pas une coupe du
monde c'était une volonté d'être
athlétique est proche et comme les gens
et les affinités
hier la victoire de sandra offerte la
cavalière allemande et d'ogden nouveau
le bas normand a été une joie immense
pour toute la famille berlioz
dès qu'on a toutes les deux premiers ont
négligé non mais ça y est je t'es bon
l'humoriste de super on avait lavé puis
certainement un couple maintenant à
michael chopra que en doute proche que
porte il ya des façons faute de quoi on
est toujours content manquera t tout ça
il mérite
il mérite tout le monde traite pas ce
qui la campagne dont jean médailles d'or
en individuel depuis la victoire dogbé
nouveau leur ancien poulain le téléphone
n'arrête pas de sonner journalistes mais
surtout professionnels de la filière
s'intéresse de très près aux arabes où
je suis comblée dans les espoirs j'ai
encore des points j'aurais jamais
bonsoir andré jacques goupil vous êtes
notre consultant les speakers du cso
cette semaine celle foncé médaille d'or
qui puisait dans l'épreuve extrêmement
compliqué difficile qu'est le cross et
paraît le mieux voilà comme quoi c'est
bien d'avoir des complexes
non mais sérieusement et puis c'est pas
le premier ce sera pas daigné et on n'a
rien à envier à tous les autres et faire
des bons shows et yves il a remarqué
tout de suite et se sont invités à un
cavalier russes italiens allemands bon
c'est l'égalité avec l'élevage allemand
être est un petit peu plus légendaires
mais voilà complexe faut faire naître
des bons chevaux et on en fait n'être
donc ça dure alors cette victoire c'est
aussi un encouragement pour les éleveurs
mais aussi pour tous les professionnels
du monde et qu'un appel a participé
aujourd'hui aux premières assises de la
filière équine c'était aujourd'hui à
l'initiative du conseil des chevaux de
basse-normandie l'idée c'est de
pérenniser ces jeux en faisant en sorte
que le monde équin qui représente quand
même douze mille six cents emplois dans
la région parle d'une seule voix
collaborent monte des projets on en
parle avec vous bonsoir laurence meunier
vous êtes vice président du conseil des
chevaux et présidente du pôle ya le pôle
de compétitivité de la filière équine le
seul en france 2 à l'univers sportif
ces jeux sont vraiment une occasion
unique d'apporter une visibilité sur la
filière fort parce qu'il ne faut pas
passer à côté
absolument je crois que c'est une
occasion comme vous dites tout à fait
unique pendant quinze jours on allait
les projecteurs du
dentier de la filière qui sont braqués
sur nous notre force en basse-normandie
et la victoire du cheval normand nous le
prouve que nous avons d'énormes savoir
faire d'énormes compétences humaines à
terroir extraordinaire une culture une
histoire formidable mais que nous avons
souvent un peu de mal à faire savoir et
éveillant sans gars travaillent ensemble
i polliat ça marche il faudrait ce que
qui se passe la même chose dans la
filière équine ans va coûter pour vous
je vous m'amenez à part les études des
assises dont je sors je n'ai même pas pu
assister à la fin ce que je regrette
pour être sur votre plateau avons
conversé en dix minutes
c'est ce qui est ressorti de ces assises
c'était absolument passionnant où s
france et le conseil des chevaux en sait
quelque chose de formidable qui va je
suis sûr
enfin en prendre aux dates pour la
filière et il est ressorti quoi
effectivement nous sommes encore
beaucoup trop dispersée beaucoup trop
atomisées les chevaux c'est cent mille
chevaux en france diminue en europe
c'est une filière une vraie filière de
passionnés mines mafia économique aussi
hélas le pôle de compétitivité est là
justement pour faire valoir toutes ces
entreprises connaissent qu'un cheval
c'est très bien s'il n'y a pas une
multitude d'entreprises
à côté on peut rien en faire ce qu'il ya
plein d'intérêts individuels et
indépendants dans le monde du cheval a
éludé monde du cheval
c'est ce n'est que ça énorme richesse
c'est l'énorme problème est à la fois il
ya ce problème là et puis en plus
quelque chose je crois qui est très
particulier à notre filière c'est
qu'elle est extrêmement riche d'un passé
fort culturel comme je le disais est
vraiment maintenant prendre le passage
du modernisme
la mère dit mais c'est aujourd'hui la
société avancer très vite ces dernières
années le monde du cheval commence
vraiment vert et le pôle de
compétitivité y contribuer je crois en
tout cas je m'y emploie toutes mes
forces
merci beaucoup laurence meunier ce que
vous dites et était entendu c'est ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on souhaite
illustration de la diversité de la
filière équine avec métier qui a été
reconnue récemment il s'agit de dentiste
équin ils ne sont qu'une vingtaine en
battant l'indien reportages réalisés
avec franck gaudreault
elle sillonne les routes de normandie
depuis quatre ans bara on écuries mode
de fortescue inspectent entretien ce
fait les bouches chevaux qui s'ils le
pouvaient s'en passerait bien
je passe est très simple la gentille car
les chevaux n'ont pas toujours eu besoin
de soins dentaires du temps où ils
broutent elle est verte prairie la
corrosivité de l'herbe suffisait à limay
lors dents qui poussent en permanence la
domestication à modifier leurs habitudes
alimentaires et a donc créé le besoin
que je crois sont au coût en boxe à
manger des choses qui sont quand même
moins abrasion l'herbe mais on a besoin
de faire le dentiste mot nivelle les
dents de lutins exprime toute fissure
dans les points micky pour aider c'est
la nuit du cheval via l'action du mort
une intervention qui se fait
généralement une fois par an sauf pour
les grands et d'alice qui y recourent
plus niveau des cavaliers peuvent avoir
parfois des réactions brutales ou
incompréhensibles du cheval au contact
de leurs mains et donc qu'ils nous
appellent pour essayer de d'aplanir de
résoudre un petit peu cette cette
relation difficile entre les deux il est
bien loin le temps où les
maréchaux-ferrants facile de mousse
dedans a fait savoir ferrer un cheval la
profession de technicien dentaire et
qu'un s'est structuré et été
officiellement reconnu les trois ans
aujourd'hui les locaux ont beaucoup
évolué ils permettent de faire des soins
je raconterai facilité et sans avoir à
exarchia utiliser une débauche d'énergie
gigantesque et en cas de problème lors
d'une extraction dedans par exemple et
autistes peuvent solliciter l'aide des
vétérinaires pour une anesthésie car
pour eux comme pour nous le passage chez
le dentiste et un moment redouté mais ou
bien nécessaire ils ont même connu on ne
leur met pas de fausses dents on choisit
pas encore peut-être chipeau les
aliments y réfléchir allez au revenant
aux jeux équestres mondiaux côté
business si la semaine dernière on a
entendu pas mal de commerçants se
plaindre du manque de fréquentation sur
le village des jeux en centre-ville ce
n'est pas la même musique les magasins
et est ouvert hier dimanche et la
clientèle étrangère des jeux a fait des
heureux pierre-marie piot pratique mertz
c'est la rentrée et les ressemble léger
un peu comme s'il faisait beau avait le
sourire et c'est à dire que les affaires
sont plutôt bonnes
oui très bonne beaucoup d'étrangers qui
viennent et à la famille par exemple ce
client est autrichien mon frère voulait
faire du shopping pour acheter des
fringues on est attaquant on en profite
pour faire un tour en ville
donc vous êtes ici chez vous et pour le
shopping la compétition et celle de
spectateurs sont à deux pas du centre
ville de caen c'est vrai les rues ne
sont pas bondée mais les quelques
échappées des jeux semblent bien avoir
embelli la fin de l'été et des ventes
qui ne se serait pas fait certainement
certainement fait et vous arrivez à
chiffre est à peu près que la proportion
d'une boutique à l'autre
les retombées sont évidemment très
agréable mais les commerçants que nous
avons rencontrés ne tient pas c'est
quand même un signe
notre point fait l'unanimité ce client
d'abord venu par amour du cheval sont
jugés très agréable c'est une classe
avec un petit peu un petit peu de sous
les commerçants ça ah bah oui on a
l'impression de travailler pour quelque
chose
allez on va passer au programme sportif
la voltige comment se demande zénith et
vous le voyez l'équipe de france était à
l'entraînement aujourd'hui la voltige
c'est un mélange d'équitation de
gymnastique et de danse pense le disco
corico le meilleur voltigeur au monde
est français il s'appelle nicolas
andréani le voici
et puis les fois que la marseillaise
retentisse vendredi soir jacques ferrari
aussi notre français très fort andré
jacques goupil le cheval est noté
également voltige c'est un vrai vrai
sport d'équipé quand moi qu'on pourrait
imaginer et d'aller marquer c'est pas un
cheval d'arçons
cette petite fête la bouche et si elle
bouge mâle leurs coûts
en une minute pour évoluer c'est la
catastrophe
le voltigeur ou la voltigeuse le cheval
la personne qui est au bout de la longue
voilà les trois doit faire qu'un en une
minute et noter qu'il reste de la place
pour la voltige vous pourrez acheter vos
billets et sur le site toile que c'est
sur le net facebook
jeudi ce sera le début des épreuves
d'attelage sur l'hippodrome de la
prairie
une épreuve qui se déroule en trois
temps le dressage le marathon et la
maniabilité
il devait donner un par la précision des
meneurs et là l'esprit de la discipline
sont plutôt néerlandaise australienne
c'est toute une tradition faut pas
oublier encore une fois que ce type est
là nous ont permis en permis lumens et
se déplacer depuis les temps jusqu'à
l'arrivée des moteurs
là c'est devenu un sport cb ne rien
c'est puissant c'est esthétique c'est
plein de rebondissements et je prends au
niveau du visuel les gens vont vraiment
se régaler ses baignades oui alors
demain c'est l'épreuve reine le concours
de saut d'obstacles cso dont vous êtes
le speaker andrée jacques le but de
passer toute une série d'obstacles sans
faire tomber une seule bas le tout le
plus vite possible
les barons finale sont quand même à un
mètre soixante dans l'équipe de france 3
bas normands qui font partie du 10
mondial et une staut pénélope leprévost
patrice delaveau et le quatrième est
bien connu son nom aujourd'hui
depuis quelques heures seulement ça y
est c'était jérôme hurel soit simon
delestre c'est simon delestre avec ti
goy margot qui a été choisi pour être
quatrième de l'équipe et ce sera ainsi
la semaine ça va commencer par l'épreuve
de vitesse demain 153 partant pour que
dimanche il ne reste plus que tapez vous
imaginez la sélection donc est-ce que
d'aller vite mais pas trop vite parce
que la faute va coûter 4 secondes et
peut déjà pénalisés tout le monde double
pression pour pratiquement tous les
cavaliers pressions individuelles et la
pression de la nation et de l'équipe
pour que le deuxième jour le troisième
jour et ne reste plus que dix équipes et
50 individuel quatrième jour trente
cavaliers seulement et le dernier la
finale tournante me tiens ton que c'est
un vrai thriller plein de
rebondissements je suis incapable
qui va gagner on suivra ça alors on
espère avoir autant un d'émotion que la
semaine dernière si vous n'y étiez pas
voyez ce qui s'est passé avec florent
turpin
tout commence par un grand défilé
ambiance
j o au stade d'ornano dans une grande
cavalcade la normandie accueille toute
la planète cheval et ses jeux équestres
mondiaux
hugo par une cérémonie ma foi très
réussis toujours plus tard en selle pour
le tressage shaq fu costumes et une
mauvaise surprise la pluie débarque
aussi à ses gros sabots
ironie du sort c'est une anglaise qui va
ensoleiller cette première semaine
une cavalière de sa majesté au nom très
français
charlotte du jardin de médailles d'or
mon argent c'est déjà la grande star de
la compétition la semaine dernière on a
découvert aussi le para dressage à
l'hippodrome de caen des cavaliers
handicapés qui réalisent des prouesses à
cheval moins médiatique moins
spectaculaire mais tout aussi passionnés
schapi cowboys santiags notre coeur
c'est le reining a un petit côté far
west au parc des expositions de caen si
si le reining c'est bien un sport pas
toujours facile à comprendre c'est vrai
mais vivant est décompacté qui a dit que
l'équitation est un sport bien des les
plus belles images de la semaine
dernière nous viennent du mont saint
michel
je dis aux d'endurance 160 6 concurrents
160 kilomètres à parcourir
comme prévu le marin de l'équitation
nous a régalés comme prévu c'est un
cavalier venus du désert qui a dompté
les sables de la veille arman al maktoum
le fils de l'émir de dubaï homme plus
riche du monde
eh oui l'équitation c'est aussi du
business direction enfin le haras du pin
pour le cross du concours complet 50000
spectateurs réunis pour l'épreuve la
plus spectaculaire avec nombreuses
chutes
heureusement sans gravité c'est sur ce
cross restera l'un des moments les plus
forts de la compétition je joue pas mal
andré-jacques en gladiateur et vous pour
trouver vous pouvez retrouver un article
sur tous ses temps forts en première
semaine sur notre site internet je vous
rappelle aussi que vous pouvez avoir
toutes les compétitions également on
retrouve la chronique les pieds devant
le crottin chroniques de matthieu
bellingen ou les jeux équestres mondiaux
vue par le petit bout de la lorgnette
mètres cubes lingen qui était vendredi
dernier au haras du pin où se déroulait
concours complet aujourd'hui je vous
propose de voir un endroit que vous ne
voyez pas d'habitude c'est l'endroit où
l'on réalise les émissions de télévision
pour les uns castres alors on pourrait
se croire à bord d'un vaisseau spatial
mais en fait ça me calme au régime
l'endroit où on réalise les émissions et
la gauche ok donc snav qui aura déjà
arrivé au fond à gauche
donc j l'heure tout se prépare là pour
demain c'est très gros boulot
il ya beaucoup de monde même caméra 32
caméras y aura trois cavaliers en même
temps ce n'est pas ce moment et on va
essayer de montrer les tous les
cavaliers et on appelait ce taux qui
sont filmés on va essayer de vous
raconter l'histoire ok alors plusieurs
heures de direct
oui ça c'est la cdc cette heure sans
discontinuer
un des rares avec trois cavaliers tout
quatre minutes qui partent qui arrive va
falloir plus que dix doigts pour j'ai la
chance d'avoir beaucoup beaucoup de gens
derrière moi
on est très nombreux et on partage un
travail
alors c'est le fils aux bleus sur la
sexualisation on a pu le voir pour y
revoir ces images du concours complet du
cross sur internet d'un événement à
l'autre si dimanche prochain vous n'êtes
pas de la finale du saut d'obstacles
bien sachez que le queen mary ii sera de
retour à charbon et ce dix ans après son
voyage inaugural un moment
particulièrement attendu est à ce fait
le programme avec stéphanie côté sylvain
ruines en 2004 le queen mary était passé
par cherbourg pour son voyage inaugural
et à chaque fois qu'il a repointé le
museau de son là nord
sur les quais les cherbourgeois ont
répondu présent avec émotion cette année
il y aura deux escales du mythique
transatlantique avec ce dimanche un
programme de divertissement pour les
milliers de badauds attendus le dimanche
déjà ce qui va changer c'est que les
commerçants sont pour la plupart ouvert
conseiller quand même très important
souligné et puis également ce qui est
très important pour le public c'est
d'assister au départ du bateau puisque
ont organisé deux places autour desquels
le public pourra se présenter pour voir
le bateau partir et salué son départ ce
sera donc la digue chantraine et le noir
du quai de france dans un mois
le queen mary effectuerez un
embarquement de 300 passagers européens
à cherbourg avant la traversée jusqu'à
new york
cette fois dans une ambiance plus
intimiste mais les badauds c'est sûr on
encore là car ici l'histoire d'amour
avec la cunard d' est gravé dans le mur
ça rappelle que le passé prestigieux
cherbourg new york le passager
transatlantique qu'on mérite
effectivement toute la partie des
migrations du débit ses campagnes etc le
queen mary 2 est l'une des trente deux
escales prévues cette année à cherbourg
soit près de cinquante mille passagers
un record depuis les années 60 et mais
les chenilles vous avez une idée pour la
randonnée demain
oui les molettes c'est totalement has
been emilia ce qu'il faut c'est à petit
percheron a c'est très pratique
puis en plus c'est vrai vous avez raison
il ya des chevaux les chevaux
territoriaux ça c'est plus en plus un
laurence monial ah non les sites
extraordinaires moi qui me bats pour
l'innovation vous avez enfin trouvé une
solution à ces problèmes
tondre il peut tondre la pelouse merci
où les toits je vous rappel vous pouvez
nous retrouver sur internet demain dans
le journal de midi des reines de bignac
gros plan sur la voltige vous expliquera
tout sous la chorégraphe de l'équipe de
france qui sera très belle soirée de
demain soir à 19h vous retrouverez
sylvain rouil et andré-jacques s'il ne
s'est pas cassé la voix au concours de
saut d'obstacles qui démarre demain
alors très bonne soirée
à bientôt